hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to submachine one the
basement now this is the first part in a
long series of games I think there's ten
in total or at least there's going to be
ten when it's done and you guys
requested this one but is a puzzle
point-and-click style adventure game so
with that being said I don't know what
to expect but you guys requested it
therefore we're going to be playing it
it's supposed to be like a surreal
adventurous kind of strange bizarre
oh it's beautiful that isn't stranger
bizarre at all oh it's so relaxing and
free now I don't know if it will wait I
got a spoon oh yeah baby I'm gonna do
all the activities that a spoon requires
like spirit and stuff I don't know I'm
gonna spoon oh hey well the music
changed here so I don't know what to
expect out of these games because I've
never actually heard of them before you
guys started suggesting it oh that's a
problem so what do I need to do about
there was also HD remakes of the game
because this game was really made in
about 2005 I believe and all these are
supposed to be connected oh oh look at
that so what does that do it obviously
opens up some valve oh hey okay I got a
coin and I got a spoon if I can just put
my immense intellect to gether I'll be
able to bang these two together and call
for help
help I'm trapped in a machine that's sub
somewhere I don't know sub of one but
it's sub uh how about you you okay
alright cool can I put the coke eh
this is bizarre okay so I'm doing stuff
and I'm flanging flangers oh yes
okay so we're smarting up no it's
something here is gonna be this place is
big okay that didn't work
okay okey-dokey then I'm assuming that
the main objective is going to be try to
escape in some form or another
okey-dokey then oh hello what does it
say last summer I went camping under the
big waterfall of Kent I guess this was a
great trip for me however some people do
not understand why well I did lose my
left arm but what the hell I found out
that I have a third arm the invisible
one since then I started learning how to
use my karma arm and as soon as my
skills were those of a master it wasn't
a surprise to me when people started
turning their backs on me cuz I was
considered to be a freak I mentally ill
and only with one arm and my third arm
jutting out of my chest
funny thing I can't tell them the truth
it would be like explaining the
possibility of space travel to a
goldfish so I'm just trying to well
firstly sorry my ramblings just got a
little too rambley so I split I flipped
oh oh is that a secret okay is that
guiding me to what I need to do about
that is that talking about the Pistons
do they need to be two and two it does
okay that that is what the piston do
we're not there dammit this is
complicated we're not really I'm too
stupid okay so that's that hello what
are you are you a bomb oh boy
I love bombs can I get out of here
please thank you I don't want to blow up
the bomb just yet ding-dong
Oh
I did it somehow I didn't even know what
I was doing
cool I got tile D I've always wanted
tile D they're my favorite band besides
tenacious d it's a lighthouse is that
from the deep sleep game oh cool
now is it an accomplishment I sure did
that what am I supposed to do who are
you I'm for me game oh you are for me
I'm supposed to do something with a
spoon I do not know okay
oh that's from the flippy flangers I
flipped the flippy flangers got it okay
should i spoon this can i spoon you who
out there wants to spoon with Mark EMU
no one no takers
oh but blablabla I know shapes I know
but that goes don't everyone look at me
I'm stupid I didn't know where that when
I mean ah spoon you I'm gonna spoon you
open Open Sesame
open says a spoon you want a spoon you
want me here comes the airplane
Oh mwah mwah no all right how about this
BAM I'm dead no okay I lost my spoon
why does no one want my spoon my spoons
oh oh whoa whoa where did that come from
six six eight three four what where
where am I looking that that's a thing
six eight okay six eight three four
thank you that's exactly what I needed
to move on to blow up this bomb here six
I did it what did I did
oh boy it's a tampon no it's a thing I
know that thing is it's definitely not a
tampon
that would be Cruz haha cool that did
the thing for the thing up here the
thingy thing that's a thing Songer yeah
electricity and then there's a door open
doodad boom boom boom boom
here can I kill myself now didn't want
to do what I'm why isn't it do why isn't
it do I rather be stuck in this place
forever
no one's gonna love me when I'm stuck in
the sub machine I miss my mommy well
wonderful what did that do why is that a
thing does the coin do the coin have any
other secrets besides those weird
numbers on this nipple here ah there we
go
I need to electrify oh that was supposed
to happen for some reason why why why
why why
okay so there's only one other puzzle
left I just need to solve it and I'm
pretty sure it has something to do this
what am I doing wrong everybody oh oh
that's what I'm doing wrong did that do
a thing that did not do a damn thing
over here oh I know where that did oh I
know exactly where that did yes crystal
ancient crystal of wisdom finally I'll
be wise and not dumb I might be a little
dumb a grandfather clock you want an
ancient crystal wisdom and you kids out
there on an ancient crystal wisdom it'll
make you super wide does anybody want an
ancient crystal wisdom anybody is really
good let me tell you like you will be so
wise you never knew what was the
theoretical pangey or leaflet Midler
oh okay I had these flip-flop from what
they were okay finally my ancient
crystal wisdom finally worked on me I
have yes yes what is that Oh oh that's
the thing oh that's the thing for the
thing the thing thing thing the
grandfather clock I'm so wise look at me
look at me
yes yeah give it to me give it to me
baby I'm so wise with my ancient crystal
of wisdom are you all in print no oh I
didn't even finish my was gonna say but
whatever bing-a-ling Wow what the hell
is that oh goody goody gumdrops where am
I going now okay
hello delivery maybe it's not might be
DiGiorno
no nothing okay freedom freedom
I got freedom Oh William Wallace would
be so proud of me that didn't sound like
the footstep of freedom oh I'm done okay
well guess I'm done then okay so that's
sub-machine you guys really requested
this one and I know this game was made
like a while ago so obviously was a very
simple point-and-click puzzle game I
don't know if the other games in the
series are more involved and have
evolved over time cuz this one was made
back in O 5 so let me know what you
think of this game in the description
below you can play all the games right
now through the linked in the
description they're free for the older
versions and then the HD remakes are a
couple bucks though either way let me
know what you think thank you again
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
eat me don't eat me eat me don't eat me
again I'm like an indecisive lesbian